nobody knows how the world would look  like in 2050 except that it will be very  different from today  so the most important things to  emphasize in in education  are things like intelli  emotional intelligence  and mental stability because the one  thing that they will need for sure  is the ability to reinvent themselves  repeatedly throughout their lives it's  really the first time in history that we  don't really know what particular skills  to teach young people because we just  don't know in what kind of world they  will be living  but we do know they will have to  reinvent themselves  and especially if you think about  something like the job market maybe the  greatest problem they will face will be  psychological because at least beyond a  certain age it's very very difficult for  people to reinvent themselves